enfrentamientos en las calles de la
capital francesa mientras los
manifestantes mantienen la presión sobre
el gobierno después de que forzará la
aprobación de la Reforma a las pensiones
sin voto del parlamento
el domingo esta era la escena en el
suburbio parisino de agoniswa decenas de
manifestantes del sindicato cgt tomaron
un centro comercial local
en todo el país los manifestantes
mostraron su rechazo al proyecto de
aumentar la edad de jubilación de 62 a
64 años a esta semana habrá más
protestas y huelgas los recolectores de
basura continúan con su huelga lo que ha
dejado unas Diez mil toneladas de basura
amontonadas en las calles de París
la situación es catastrófica para los
residentes para todo París así como para
los turistas ratas durante el día cubos
de basura interminables una ciudad sucia
muy muy sucia es horrible
el sindicato de GTA advertido de que
otras dos refinerías de petróleo podrían
cerrar y el líder del sindicato dice que
sus miembros no piensan echarse atrás
pronto
cada día Hay nuevas ideas eso es lo que
han pedido los sindicatos estamos aquí
para dar la voz de alarma para decir que
hay mucha rabia
los sindicatos ya han convocado una
nueva jornada de protesta para este
jueves con huelgas y concentraciones
previstas en todo el país